when you're watching all this going on
how do you think about the press as a
founder with
not a lot of investors and you know a
ton of revenue do you even bother with
the press do you have a press strategy
how do you look
at the press as somebody with an
at-scale business um
you know obviously the press is
important because they can help amplify
a story so like if you can do it well
then it's it's advantageous
uh but it is tricky like you you know uh
you're competing with
things that get clicks uh and so you
know there's a lot of hard-working
people in press
that are trying to write good stories do
good work
but as a culture as a society we like
watching a train wreck
right uh and so it's hard when you're
running one of these business saying
like hey i want to write a feel-good
story when
as a culture like that's not what we
want to watch we love watching this
people dunk on each other that's what we
like and so there's
i i think there's more systemic problem
here where it's like
like as a society how can we get our
attention more on things that actually
are
generating positive good things
happening in society
and try and just move more that
direction instead of
you know watching things fall apart all
around us is the
is the ascension of podcasting because
you kind of alluded to this monique and
i think it's a really
interesting and subtle point the
ascension of podcasting in a way
is a reaction to
the dissension and the degrading of
journalism
in print or journalism in
text they're not making any money there
they're quoting us out of context there
they're desperately trying to get clicks
so they will
spin the stories to be as tribal and
you know aggressive as possible
sometimes to the point as in this case
where it's just
a goof it's a serious story and they
made it goofy like you could write
you could really lean on silicon valley
to give you very good insights you could
have gone to google you could have gone
to facebook and said hey do you have any
data
on how coronavirus is being talked about
and does that relate in some way to
how the you know this is spreading
there's so many ways you could spend
this